there was a guy at the Trump rally who  it's whenever they mention anyone who's  gay like there's a comment about uh  Marjorie Taylor green mentioned Pete  boot Edge  and she just can't avoid a homophobic  comment when she mentions a gay person  here is a guy who mentions mentions  Anderson Cooper and again like makes  just a weird homophobic comment first  Prime Minister in a Catholic hardcore  country and she won with that much  Landslide where is all of them to be  happy with it right nothing zero zip  silent CNN they don't say anything and  what's his name he is a gay he's  supposed to support that no for women's  rent  Anderson Cooper is a gay as this  individual points out and therefore  Anderson Cooper should like the new  radical neo-fascist prime minister of  Italy because she's a woman and gay men  like women's rights quite a political  analysis from this gentleman really  interesting